eh fils qu'est-ce que tu fais là tu mets
les mains sur la grille
et ça c'est quoi ça
c'est du cristal non
le cristal une drogue de synthèse une
des moins chères une des plus fortes
laisse tomber la drogue ça t'apporte
rien ça va te créer que des problèmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je viens d'atterrir au Mexique 12 heures
de vol et 20 degrés au sol ici il n'y a
pas d'hiver c'est la Californie
mexicaine
au bout de l'autoroute Tijuana au bout
de Tijuana le Pacifique
s'il y avait des touristes il prendra en
photo les mariachis
les catcheurs
où les guinguettes de rue
mais il n'y a pas de touristes à tiwana
seulement du béton des voitures et des
centres commerciaux XXL
et puis partout des enseignes en dollars
c'est le dernier arrêt avant les
États-Unis
en face l'autre Californie l'américaine
celle qui fait rêver
les gratte-ciels de San Diego on les
aperçoit à l'oeil nu sur la plage de
tiwana
mais entre les deux Californie il y a
une frontière au sud le Mexique et au
nord le pays le plus riche du monde
au bord de l'Eldorado tiroir
la frontière fait vivre les gens
et les fait mourir
ceux qui veulent passer au Nord et ceux
qui trafiquent avec le Nord
[Musique]
immigration et drogue les deux business
de la ville
pour le tourisme on passera
à Tijuana je partirai avec des
journalistes de faits divers branchés
sur les fréquences de la police
j'irai sur des scènes de crimes
l'ultra-violence au quotidien
et je suivrai des patrouilles de nuit
avec course-poursuite et arrestation
coup de poing
j'entrerai en prison sécurité maximum
pour mater les gang
[Musique]
je visiterai des bordels géant gérer
d'une main de fer
et puis je verrai l'envers du rêve
américain sur le visage de ses fantômes
sans abri toxicoman ils sont restés du
mauvais côté de la frontière
bienvenue à Tijuana la dernière ville du
Far West avec en poche un passeport pour
le crime
pour connaître un pays il faut goûter sa
cuisine
c'est comme ça que j'aime voyager
[Musique]
je suis un chef depuis 20 ans à Paris
j'ai deux étoiles au Michelin mais à
l'étranger ce que je préfère c'est la
cuisine de rue la street food
[Musique]
au Mexique le tacos est roi on le met à
toutes les sauces verdict
c'est vraiment un jeu de texture parce
qu'on a le croustillant du du tacos et
en même temps on a le jus encore de la
viande qui est là et sauce piquante qui
relève qui donne du relief et pour
adoucir le tout guacamole prêt
c'est parfait alors c'est pas très
facile à manger on salit un peu les
doigts mais c'est juste délicieux
bon et populaire ça me parle
aujourd'hui je travaille dans un palace
mais j'ai grandi dans une cité j'ai pas
mal bourlingué
j'ai été militaire dans une première vie
j'ai servi au Liban par la perdre de
l'année comme on dit
donc même pour gagner quelques pesos
dans la rue et bien faut payer le bout
de trottoir et des en fonction du
quartier c'est pas forcément une façon
extrêmement légale
on n'est pas
dans le dans le 20e là
[Musique]
cette nuit les choses sérieuses
commencent je suis avec la division des
homicides
[Musique]
le patron c'est lui commissaire RIMENEZ
on vient de signaler un homme mort dans
une chambre d'hôtel
[Musique]
voici l'endroit l'hôtel paradis le mal
de mai
ici la victime a vécu l'enfer
allez on y va
autorisation exceptionnelle nous allons
pouvoir filmer la scène de crime
pour l'instant personne ne rentre il
faut laisser travailler la police
scientifique
nous allons travailler ici un moment
avec les experts pour essayer de
déterminer le mobile du crime et
découvrir quelle est la cause de la mort
de la victime
et tu as bien également l'heure de la
mort
le matelas n'est plus à sa place y
a-t-il eu affrontement
en tout cas les grandes lignes du
scénario sont élastiques
regardez la victime ses mains sont
attachées avec du scotch
c'est un assassinat
l'équipe scientifique fait son rapport
les indications je vais te les donner
dans le sens Nord ou est
[Musique]
il y a une tâche là
c'est inspectrice en civile à l'oeil les
scientifiques venaient de passer à côté
d'un indice
faire une analyse de la tâche pour
savoir si c'est du sang ou pas
analyse immédiate avec un réactif si
c'est du sang la couleur va virer
[Musique]
c'est positif et voilà un neuvième
indice une tâche de sang
sur le palier le réceptionniste de
l'hôtel répond aux premières questions
de la police puis autre
je suis venu checker sa chambre pour
voir si on pouvait faire le ménage j'ai
toqué à la porte j'ai ouvert et j'ai
découvert le corps dans la salle de bain
vous le connaissez non je connaissais
sous le nom de Roberto mais rien de plus
seulement Roberto la personne je la
connaissais pas il est arrivé il y a
combien de temps une semaine ouais cinq
jours à peu près 5 pas possible ici
c'est la frontière tu vois ce que je
veux dire
dans la chambre les experts ont fait
entrer les enquêteurs
sur cette partie et que l'on procède
ensuite par ici on y va
les indices sont maintenant répertoriés
et mis sous scellés
ensuite il y a une bouteille d'eau
minérale de la marque ciel d'un litre et
celle-ci elle fait 50 cl
une sandale une bouteille une paille le
labo trouvera peut-être des empreintes
ou des traces ADN
mais une chambre d'hôtel ça voit défiler
des clients et des ADN
[Musique]
ce sont des poils là
il y en a au moins 50 000
et ben avec ça on va en retrouver qui
appartient à des gens qu'on connaît
même au poulet qu'on a tué sur la plage
se bouge c'est bien un endroit pour les
poulets
humour noir du commissaire qui va ouvrir
la valise de la victime
tout au fond une enveloppe
une simple photo de famille la victime
avec probablement ses enfants
il en faudrait plus pour émouvoir le
commissaire
dans son pantalon avec sa ceinture dorée
ça doit être un moustachu style du fin
fond des canyons tu vois
le commissaire de plaisance à moitié
la ceinture de Nana 10 la boucle est
typique de la région de Sinaloa célèbre
pour son cartel sanguinaire
l'assassinat sans le règlement de compte
entre narcotrafiquant
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde
s'est habitué à ce niveau de violence
c'est insupportable c'est insupportable
après tout les codes liés
aux exécutions comme ça elles sont
forcément
sont forcément des messages
qui a des ongles pour arracher le
sparadrap
non non j'en ai pas vous voulez quoi
ici il y a des ciseaux
à lui il a un couteau
le commissaire nous demande d'arrêter de
tourner
les pompes funèbres emmènent le corps
pour l'autopsie
la police condamne la chambre
mauvaise publicité pour l'hôtel paradis
quels sont les causes du décès ce soir
ça a l'air assez violent quand même
comme situation et cette taille
il a été bâillonné à l'aide d'une bande
adhésive de couleur bleue et il est mort
le B a-t-il été torturé a-t-on voulu le
faire parler connaissait-il les
assassins
pas sûr que l'enquête aboutisse un jour
à Tijuana il y a plus de questions que
de réponses
drogue et immigration les deux business
de tiwana hier soir j'étais dans
l'univers des narcos ce matin je vais
entrevoir celui des émigrés la moitié de
la ville n'a plus d'électricité
un énorme transformateur a été coupé
à cause de cet homme qui a escaladé les
installations
les pompiers sont là avec la police et
même l'armée
[Musique]
les journalistes à court
un homme un émigré qui menace de suicide
[Musique]
journaliste pour l'hebdomadaire la
Frontera la frontière en français
je fais une vidéo de tout
pour tout raconter
l'homme peut sauter à tout moment
on dirait qu'il s'agrippe à l'espace de
bar là
super fine il va se fatiguer
son nom est Yann Carlos il aurait 29 ans
et serait originaire du mitchwakan il
aurait été reconduit à la frontière par
les États-Unis et déclare que sa vie ne
vaut plus rien
certains policiers ici m'ont dit qu'ils
avaient demandé l'assistance de l'armée
et des policiers fédéraux
ils sont effectivement venus en renfort
ok merci
web pour raconter ce qui se passe en
détail
d'informations et on sait pas trop
comment ça va se terminer
le suicidaire refuse de descendre mais
il n'y a pas de revendication juste le
malheur d'avoir été expulsé par les
États-Unis pas simple de négocier avec
lui
[Musique]
le moyen de négocier avec lui parce que
c'est aussi dangereux pour lui que pour
la personne qui va monter le chercher
parce que ça peut bouger ils peuvent
tomber
il est bientôt midi
se tient toujours au bord du vide depuis
près de six heures
quand tout à coup
[Applaudissements]
les secouristes bondissent mais il a
fait une chute de 15 mètres
s'il vous plaît reculez
s'il vous plaît monsieur
c'est très triste
de voir ça
en plus le jour de l'amour et l'amitié
la Saint-Valentin
je pensais que ça aurait pu se finir
autrement
mais il avait vraiment décidé d'en finir
[Musique]
résumé du soir sur le site du journal El
Frontera le jeune homme qui ce matin a
sauté du haut d'une installation
électrique a été immédiatement prise en
charge par les secours et emmener à
l'hôpital où sont décès a été constaté
chef des pompiers a déclaré que l'homme
possédait toutes ses facultés mentales
il était vendeur de hot-dog aux
États-Unis avant d'être reconduit à la
frontière il n'avait pas de famille à
Tijuana
un million 600 000 habitants et autant
de destins qui tousse ramène à la
frontière
je veux la voir cette frontière qui
vient de causer la mort d'un homme sous
mes yeux avec un passeport français je
suis un migrant légal direction Santis
Diderot c'est le plus gros poste
frontière au monde
vu du ciel un immense entonnoir
et ça ne s'arrête jamais 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7
nous sommes dimanche il est 10h du matin
et c'est déjà l'embouteillage
autour des voitures des centaines de
vendeurs à la sauvette
on trouve de tout sandwich boisson
journaux vêtements et même des jouets
pour les enfants
il y a 15 voix de front mais ça ne
suffit pas
alors on passe aussi à pied pour aller
travailler visiter un proche ou faire du
shopping
chaque jour un demi million de
frontaliers passe par là
côté mexicain personne mais côté
américain des caméras des capteurs des
douaniers méfiants
ils ont des chiens dressés à l'odeur de
la cocaïne ou de la chair humaine
interdit de tourner nous filmons ces
quelques images avec un téléphone
[Musique]
ça y est nous voilà aux États-Unis
c'est assez surréaliste
c'est à vivre parce que vous mettez dans
la peau de l'immigrants pour l'avoir
vécu moi dans d'autres pays d'avoir été
un émigré dans d'autres pays ça fait
quelque chose
santéidro c'est pour ceux qui ont les
papiers pour dissuader les autres il y a
ça un mur
1200 km de mur répartis sur les points
stratégiques tout au long de cette
frontière immense de 3200 km entre
Atlantique et Pacifique à tiwana le mur
plonge même dans l'océan
avec 5 mètres de hauteur il est presque
infranchissable
ça c'est le vieux mur le mur de
l'opération gardien de la frontière
cet homme est né du bon côté du mur
Enrique
depuis 20 ans il lutte contre la
politique d'immigration de son pays les
États-Unis
ça c'est le nouveau mur construit sous
le président Bush
il est bien plus haut il est plus
difficile à franchir aussi
là vous voyez mon bras est du côté
mexicain là c'est le Mexique
et là c'est les États-Unis ils ont
commencé leur périple Mexique ou plus
loin ils arrivent ici au pied du mur se
cachent ils attendent que les gardes
frontières soient occupées et ils
essaient d'escalader
chaque jour une vague humaine vient se
briser sur la frontière
hier soir un homme est mort il venait de
franchir le mur surpris par les gardes
frontières il a lancé une pierre
le garde la battu
lé
juste parce qu'il avait faim il a pas pu
rentrer par la grande porte il a paniqué
il a lancé une pierre et il a été tué
mais il y a encore plus efficace que le
mur le désert
[Musique]
glacial la nuit
brûlant le jour
beaucoup de migrants meurent de froid ou
de soif
c'est pour eux Enrique dépose des
bouteilles d'eau au
hasards
[Musique]
se cacher ici il fait hyper chaud ils
prennent l'eau et évite il repartent
donc on laisse de l'eau à des endroits
stratégiques
et vous passez chaque jour chaque
semaine chaque semaine
tu vois là on en a déjà mis
et là aussi
elle sera tiède elle aura pris le goût
de plastique mais pour ceux qui ont soif
ce sera un petit miracle une main tendue
sur la route
[Musique]
retour côté mexicain au poste frontières
il est 22h mais il y a toujours du
trafic
[Musique]
une petite cérémonie s'organise en
mémoire du migrant abattu hier
[Musique]
je suis indigné
je suis en colère parce qu'ils ont tué
un mexicain de plus
ça aurait pu être moi ça aurait pu être
mon cousin mon ami
ça aurait pu être n'importe qui hé les
gars on ramène les bougies maintenant
c'est quelque chose d'inacceptable tu
comprends
ça nous fait vraiment de la peine
[Musique]
la nuit sera longue
j'embarque avec la police pour une
patrouille
prise de service
garde à vous
équipement Robocop fusil d'assaut gilet
pare-balles et casque lourd
nous allons maintenant commencer cette
patrouille en formation allez
lui c'est le patron de l'unité
commandant Lara
je connaissais personnellement tous ces
hommes j'ai travaillé avec eux
14 morts en 12 ans même pour des
policiers sur armés les rues de tiruana
ne sont pas sûr
départ de la patrouille
[Musique]
un convoi de trois voitures pour limiter
les risques et pour montrer sa force
[Musique]
de couleur noire
GTB 57 78
[Musique]
de maraude
une démission de la police d'État et la
prévention
comment fait-on de la prévention et bien
par exemple en arrêtant les véhicules
suspects
et comment on reconnaît un véhicule
suspect c'est simple c'est une voiture
sportive aux vitres teintées les narcos
ont toujours eu le goût pour le bling
bling
cette fois-ci tout est en règle
la patrouille reprend
minuit appel d'urgence on signale à
kidnapping
sirène hurlante et 160 km heure au
compteur
on se dirige vers le Rosarito sur le
lieu des événements
le kidnapping a eu lieu dans un bar
d'hôtel
[Musique]
on va se garer
en voiture par ici c'est quel calibre du
40 ou 45
[Musique]
donc ils sont passés par là et ensuite
ils sont entrés directement
tu vois ils ont tiré depuis cet
endroit-là
il y a des caméras
c'est quoi 45
ils ont pris un serveur aussi
les kidnappeurs ont pris tous les
risques l'endroit était bondé
[Applaudissements]
ils ont tiré dans la foule c'est un
miracle il n'y a pas de victimes
les clients et les filles se sont
envolés comme des moineaux
restent serveur choqués
par là et on commençait à se battre des
gens se sont levés et d'autres sont
entrés aussi par derrière
il voulait tous nous voler
mais tu sais menacé avec des armes
longues pas une minute à perdre les
kidnappeurs n'ont pas eu le temps
d'aller très loin
personne ne pourra partir par là
autour du commandant des hommes de
l'Antigone venus en renfort
la chasse peut commencer
les kidnappeurs ont un gros 4 4 de
couleur sombre
juste comme celui-ci il tente de fuir
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
erreur sur la personne ces jeunes de
bonne famille n'ont pas le profil
les recherches vont durer toute la nuit
sans succès
conférence de presse le lendemain matin
au siège de la police
je retrouve Luis le journaliste del
Frontera je l'avais croisé le jour de se
suicide spectaculaire
nous sommes en contact avec la famille
de la victime
des infos sur la personne qui a été
enlevée hier à Rosarito non de toute
façon cette affaire ne relève pas de
notre juridiction il faut voir avec le
procureur de Rosarito mais d'après
l'information qu'on a eu au groupe anti
kidnapping c'est une tentative de
privation de liberté on est allé sur
place pour vérifier mais non ce n'est
pas un enlèvement
attention à la subtilité juridique pour
qu'il y a officiellement kidnapping il
faut une demande de rançon sinon c'est
une simple privation de liberté et ça
fait mieux dans les statistiques de la
police la com s'accompte d'ailleurs
l'inspecteur a une petite surprise pour
les médias un kidnappeur en chair et en
os arrêtez dans une autre affaire le
voici livré aux questions des reporters
impensable en France
à combien de kidnapping tu as participé
un petit poisson pas encore jugé mais
qui sera sur toutes les télévisions dans
quelques minutes visage non flouté ça ne
choque pas Louis
si nous avons droit de poser des
questions et nous passionnés
le kidnappeur part en détention
préventive à quoi ressemble les prisons
de Tijuana
[Musique]
je prends la route de l'Est direction el
rogonne une prison ultra moderne
construite en plein désert
[Musique]
paysage minéral ici on pourrait repérer
les évadés de loin
[Musique]
derrière les murs près de 1000 détenus
c'est la plus grande prison de la région
mais surtout c'est une prison moderne
inaugurée il y a 5 ans seulement
le directeur en personne me fait la
visite
[Musique]
une seule consigne interdiction de
parler aux prisonniers
[Musique]
dans ce complexe pénitencier on a par
ici les détenus qui sont les moins
dangereux et par là tous ceux qui
représentent un risque plus élevé
et là on a les modules de vie avec
l'école et la cantine
en France je donne des cours de cuisine
en prison je vais pouvoir faire la
comparaison des deux univers carcéraux
[Musique]
suite de la visite le PC sécurité
ultra moderne lui aussi
rien échappe à l'oeil des 170 caméras de
la prison
je sélectionne la caméra et avec ce
simple joystick je la dirige ou je veux
et je peux même zoomer là par exemple je
vois tout le terrain de sport et je peux
zoomer comme ça
est-ce qu'il y a déjà eu des tentatives
d'évasion
jusqu'à aujourd'hui non c'est parce que
nous respectons scrupuleusement toutes
les procédures tous les jours 24 heures
sur 24 samedi et dimanche
24 heures sur 24 les caméras tournent
même en cellule intimité nulle
les cellules justement c'est la
prochaine étape de la visite
tout le monde au fond
les mains dans le dos en ligne allez au
fond au fond
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du
[Musique]
petit signe du gardien c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et là pour vol
ils sont peu dangereux
et ici c'est leur lit
chacun a son espace et son numéro
informatique avec tous leurs dossiers
comme vous pouvez voir chaque détenu a
une carte avec un code barre
d'identification
il suffit de flasher le code barre et
tout l'historique du détenu apparaît
et que se passera-t-il si la technologie
un jour passe entre de mauvaises mains
nous approchons maintenant d'un lieu
sensible
[Musique]
une pièce forte l'armurerie de la prison
c'est le HK c'est 62 c'est une arme
percutante
donc là on a affaire du matériel
lourd en termes de
l'intervention
je suis un ancien commando parachutiste
et j'ai gardé un respect pour les armes
comme toujours tout dépend des hommes
qui les manipulent il y a 1000 hommes
contenus dans ces dans ce pénitencier ça
peut vite vite partir
dans des zones de conflits assez intense
donc il faut protéger les personnels et
protéger
la société aussi
[Musique]
quelques portes blindées plus loin
jantes dans une autre sorte d'armurerie
celle des détenus
[Musique]
tout ici peut-être utilisé comme des
armes ici sont entreposés tous les
outils comme les marteaux pour chaque
outil on met le nom qui correspond à la
photo
[Musique]
il y a un contrôle immédiat
simple et efficace de l'hyperprudence
pour éviter l'hyperviolence
[Musique]
mais inexplicable c'est ce qui ne l'ont
jamais fréquenté tant mieux pour eux
l'univers de la détention
même pour un visiteur comme moi que ce
soit en France que ce soit ailleurs dans
le monde il y a toujours une atmosphère
très particulière quoi de gens qui sont
enfermés et après on peut en débattre
tout ce qu'on faut faire dans ces
centres de tension pour améliorer les
choses et surtout de créer un projet
pour la sortie c'est ça qui va être
important mais
l'atmosphère d'un centre de détention et
pesant
[Musique]
pour se détendre et penser à la sortie
il y a l'atelier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans cette prison model on fabrique des
matelas de luxe pour l'exportation
est-ce qu'il y a un salaire pour les
détenus dans une
obligation par la loi
le salaire est en trois tiers un tiers
pour indemniser les victimes un tiers
pour la famille
touche 5 euros pour 8 heures de travail
par jour c'est le tiers du salaire
minimum au Mexique mais attention aux
illusions d'optique le quotidien des
prisons mexicaine ça ressemble plutôt à
ça
ces images ont été tournées dans l'autre
prison de Tijuana bien plus ancienne et
plus violente viol raquette trafic
et une surpopulation qui fait monter la
température
en 2008 une émeute a fait 19 morts
[Musique]
se termine mais le directeur m'a préparé
une surprise
vous êtes sûrs
Charlotte obligatoire je commence à me
douter quelque chose
pour vous je suis très touché je vais le
ramener un petit peu comme un souvenir
important
tant que ce match tant que
visite des cuisines modèle forcément
ça c'est du poulet à la crème c'est le
menu du jour pour les détenus
pour l'infini en tortilla l'autre
classique mexicain après le tacos
[Musique]
ils ont tous des gestes de cuisiniers et
ils font les choses avec application
chaque recette nous l'a détaillons pour
leur apprendre les bases comment couper
les légumes comment cuire et à quelle
température l'idée c'est de leur
transmettre un savoir-faire
le chef se lance sous mes yeux dans une
petite création champignon soja l'art
oignons on sort des standards mexicains
il fait un petit twist
ique je crois que c'est pour l'accueil
parce qu'il sait que j'aime bien la
clinique japonaise
quelques gouttes de crème de soja pour
le lion la cuisine ça fait aussi voyager
c'est important en détention donc là il
a trouvé le moyen de nous faire voyager
hors qu'on est quasiment en plein milieu
du désert c'est quand même pas mal
comment vous trouvez
il est temps de retourner en ville
à tiwana je ne suis pas au bout de mes
surprises je croiserai les fantômes du
rêve américain ceux qui ont vécu aux
États-Unis avant d'en être expulsés et
qui traîne depuis dans des terrasses je
suis vrai à photographe de faits divers
dans sa folle journée passant d'une
scène de crime à l'autre j'entrerai avec
une caméra cachée dans des bordels
géants ouverts 24 heures sur 24 et je
vivrai en direct l'arrestation d'un
baron de la drogue avec la saisie de son
arsenal
quand la nuit tombe sur Tijuana on le
voit qu'elle
éclairée comme un stade de foot longue
comme une blessure
elle coupe le paysage en deux la
frontière
même la nuit on y revient
et la police n'est jamais loin
patrouille de routine c'est pas une
voiture là au fond
une silhouette comme si ce no man's land
était habitée
[Applaudissements]
des migrants expulsés par les États-Unis
beaucoup de drogués pour survivre ils
travaillent en ville
sergent chef Hector lui et ses collègues
de la police municipale seront floutés
pour gagner quelques sous ils font la
manche il lave des voitures mais
beaucoup d'entrevolent c'est un vrai
problème
là il y a environ 3000 personnes qui
vivent ici ils se sont construits des
abris même sous terre c'est un gros
problème pour nous
3000 personnes une petite ville on a du
mal à y croire
il y a des humains qui vivent ici
pas une maison ni même un abri
plutôt intérieur avec quelques objets
personnels sauvés d'une phrase
il y a personne
tout se connecte là
je vais te trouver un bâton
une sorte de lance artisanale peut-être
pour se protéger des agressions
le collègue d'Hector a trouvé autre
chose
tous les sens abris ils l'ont repris
pour eux mais c'est plutôt la sainte
patronne des narcos normalement
on la retrouve même dans les maisons des
narcos
chance
pour qu'il n'arrive jamais rien à leurs
affaires ou alors cargaison de drogue
[Musique]
les narcos au moins ont un toit une
famille des projets ces invisibles eux
n'ont rien c'est le peuple des terriers
je reviendrai en plein jour pour les
rencontrer
[Musique]
nous partons pour le centre-ville nous
sommes samedi soir
la police vient de recevoir un appel
le patron d'un café internet c'est plein
je crois à droite ou à gauche non non
pas plus loin il y a trop de trafic là
tu es jeune on fumé du shit devant les
ordinateurs
et toi aussi fiston allez tous là-bas
un petit coup d'oeil à l'intérieur il y
a une odeur de chute mais apparemment
pas de fumeur
tout ce que vous avez
[Musique]
ça aussi
il faut qu'on vérifie qu'ils sont pas
déjà recherchés
on va faire une fouille Ici vous mettez
contre le véhicule
qu'est-ce que tu fais ici ce soir moi
bah rien j'allais sortir avec ma copine
ouais c'est ça vous sortez soit disant
tous avec vos copines et les copines en
question n'arrivent jamais pas vrai non
bah
rien de suspect tu ne devrais pas fumer
on vous laisse rentrer chez vous
cette fois on ne vous emmène pas à la
prison municipale ni au centre des
mineurs
ici vous ne pouvez pas fumer vous le
savez bien ce n'est pas un secret
pour un simple joint les flics de baisse
pas les bras même si tirwana est une
décapité de la cocaïne dans le monde
[Musique]
la patrouille reprend
toi
tu mets les mains sur la grille
[Musique]
tu étais en train de boire
et ça c'est quoi ça
c'est du cristal non
le cristal une drogue de synthèse une
des moins chères une des plus fortes
[Musique]
depuis combien de temps tu prends du
cristal à peu près depuis 4 mois
[Musique]
ça va te créer que des problèmes
tu perds l'appétit le sommeil tu as de
l'énergie pendant deux trois jours de
suite et vraiment puissante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par le juge tout à l'heure
bravo
derrière les barreaux ils sont déjà
nombreux à attendre
les voici les fantômes de la frontière
ceux qui survivent dans des terriers
en ville ils lavent des voitures ou
vendre des vêtements à la sauvette cela
ont été ramassés par la patrouille
ils sont présentés au juge en costume
gris
5 minutes par cas avec au bout de
petites peines de prison entre 3h et 36
heures
arrêté parce que tu as participé à un
rassemblement sur la voie publique
pardon ce n'est pas autorisé pourquoi
parce que tu manifestais sur la voie
publique tu as des papiers tu as le
droit à un appel téléphonique
ce qu'il y a c'est que je n'ai pas de
papier pour le moment parce que j'ai été
expulsé des États-Unis on m'a volé
toutes mes affaires tu travailles en ce
moment oui mais j'ai été expulsé le fait
d'être expulsé n'est pas une activité
oui d'accord c'est un antécédent sur ta
situation juridique au Mexique
je travaille dans l'entretien je fais de
la peinture et des choses comme ça pour
survivre
est-ce que tu as une pièce d'identité
oui ou non non comme je vous disais je
n'en ai pas est-ce que tu as un
justificatif de domicile ou une preuve
de tes activités au Mexique non là
vraiment je peux rien vous montrer non
tu n'en as pas tu n'as rien
bon je vais seulement te sanctionner
pour rassemblement sur la voie publique
parce que ça contribue à l'insécurité
mettre la misère en prison à Tijuana
comme à Paris ce n'est pas une solution
on a un registre d'intervention très
large ça va de l'enfant perdu du vol à
l'arrachée jusqu'au volama armé
il y a d'autres services de police qui
nous aident mais à la police municipale
on est toujours les premiers sur place
ça oblige ces hommes finalement à avoir
une analyse très rapide avoir beaucoup
de polyvalence dans leur dans leurs
actions et beaucoup de discernement dans
leurs actions
nous on essaie toujours de dialoguer
avec les personnes avant de les
embarquer au poste chaque fois on essaie
de repérer ceux qui méritent vraiment
une arrestation
avant la population avait du mal à nous
faire confiance il y avait beaucoup de
corruption il faut dire et même des
officiers impliqués dans le trafic de
drogue et puis il y a eu une grande
épuration dans les années passées et de
nombreux policiers ripoux ont été radiés
chassés de la police
et c'est pourquoi maintenant la
population nous voit très positivement
bon allez on continue
tu as le registre
il est 22h c'est la fièvre du samedi
soir nous entrons dans le quartier rouge
[Musique]
c'est une activité illégale au Mexique
mais bon on nous la
combien sont-elles dans ces rues 2000
3000 peut-être
beaucoup d'entre elles ont voulu passer
la frontière pour aller aux États-Unis
mais elles n'ont pas réussi et elles
sont restées scotchées ici à tiwana
traite des blanches ce sont des gens qui
kidnappent des filles dans d'autres
États du Mexique et qui les forces à
venir travailler ici dans la région
parfois on a des dénonciations
signalement là on peut intervenir et
venir les sauver
qui sont ces femmes
comment survivent-elles dans ce monde
violent et masculin
un des policiers accepte de
m'accompagner après la patrouille le
voici il est en civil nous tournons en
caméra cachée nous allons nous faire
passer pour des clients ordinaires les
filles sont surveillées
[Musique]
ça fait 20 en tout
et pour toutes les positions que tu veux
non non c'est dans cette rue là que
c'est le moins cher
ici c'est vraiment une prostitution bas
de gamme
moins d'argent et plus de risques les
filles de la rue sont en bas de
l'échelle
et deux positions
de plus
si je veux quoi la fille complètement
nue c'est 15 € de plus
ces filles jusqu'à 30 clients par nuit
c'est de la bataille
et puis il y a les bars à hôtesses une
spécialité à tiroir
[Musique]
à l'entrée fouille obligatoire sage
précaution vu le nombre d'armes en
circulation
[Musique]
à l'intérieur ambiance de saloon une
centaine de strip-teaseuses deux étages
et à Barry Mans
n'oubliez pas
[Musique]
le DJ parle anglais mais tous les
clients sont mexicains les Américains
qui venaient sans cani à Tijuana ils ont
déserté depuis longtemps trop dangereux
il y a des filles sur scène et celle en
rang qui attendent le client
sécurité discrète mais bien présente
[Applaudissements]
étonnant ici on n'accepte pas les pesos
on perd en dollars
je te fais le change
combien de dollars tu veux
[Musique]
combien 50
le barman me rend 50 billets de 1 dollar
je comprends vite pourquoi
[Musique]
nous prenons une table le serveur nous
amène une fille visiblement elle n'a pas
son mot à dire qu'une deuxième et une
troisième blonde à gauche
[Musique]
elles sont à peine installées le serveur
prend déjà la commande
et toi tu es d'où je suis de Paris
un deuxième serveur vient vérifier si
nous avons bien commandé puis un
troisième
[Musique]
trois bières 20 euros un système bien
huilé
le serveur à gauche vient demander aux
filles leur numéro chacune doit
atteindre son quota et faire boire une
trentaine de bières par nuit
on va à l'hôtel
et combien
80 dollars
et tu fumes sinon non
[Musique]
si tu veux elle a de la coque aussi on
peut t'en apporter dans la chambre
la drogue n'est jamais loin
[Musique]
distraction pour les clients et
peut-être aussi évasion pour les
prostituées
[Musique]
heureusement il y a dans ce tableau des
couleurs d'espoir
ce matin j'ai rendez-vous dans un lieu
secret
les narcos donneraient cher pour
connaître l'adresse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a ici des prostituées qui leur ont
échappé
et qui se reconstruisent doucement
les filles qui n'ont pas connu de
traumatismes n'ont pas de problème pour
être touchés elle en revanche en subit
beaucoup de violence
cet atelier c'est une façon pour moi de
rentrer en contact en douceur avec elle
toute son mineur sauf Karen
aujourd'hui hello témoignait un visage
découverts et ce qu'elle raconte est
insoutenable
à l'intérieur des chambres il y avait
des caméras
le premier soir j'ai commencé de nuit de
10 heures
jusqu'à 5h du matin
et j'ai tout de suite recommencé dès 8
heures jusqu'à 2h du matin
[Musique]
sexuelles avec 25 à 30 hommes par jour
je devais rapporter 1700 euros chaque
jour
il venait me frapper
de représailles sur ma famille il me
disait que le jour où je m'enfuirai
il irait directement chez eux
de ma sœur il disait qu'il allait lui
faire la même chose et qu'il allait même
la tuer
en plus d'être violée par d'autres
hommes
lui me violette aussi il me forçait à
avoir des relations sexuelles avec lui
et aussi des relations anales
et pendant ce temps là il me frappait il
me disait que j'étais une bâtarde une
[__] bon marché
karen est là depuis deux ans et
repartira quand elle sera prête
pour ses filles brisées par la vie toute
présence masculine peut être ressentie
comme une menace
la cuisine
il faut juste battre les œufs
comment tu t'appelles
et demain
comme ça facile
la magie de la cuisine c'est quand même
créé ce lien à chaque fois peu importe
dans l'univers dans lequel on est
bonjour ça va
ok
oui ça va et toi ça va ça va
je suis prêt je suis prêt
[Rires]
[Musique]
et pommes de terre confites c'était mes
recettes mais c'est moi qui est le plus
appris aujourd'hui
bon appétit
il n'y a que deux centres comme celui-ci
au Mexique ce serait peut-être un bon
investissement dans l'ouvrir d'autres
je suis de retour à la frontière là où
j'étais hier avec la patrouille le voici
le petit peuple détaillé à découvert
écrasé de lumière et de chaleur
[Musique]
comment s'organise la vie sur ces petits
morceaux de terre est-ce que c'est
plutôt pacifique ou il y a des tensions
quand même par moments parfois c'est
difficile avec la police on a des
problèmes avec
ils ne veulent pas de nous ici alors
c'était pas simple
[Musique]
excusez-moi tout est en désordre on fait
du rangement
[Musique]
politesse du désespoir
derrière lui sa femme fait semblant de
mettre de l'ordre
[Musique]
pour survivre c'est tout c'est comme ça
a essayé de revenir en arrière de
retourner aux États-Unis
on ne nous voit pas
parfois il y en a mais pas en ce moment
et ça ça aide pour pouvoir passer de
l'autre côté
c'est comme quand il pleut tu vois
et sinon et ben on va essayer de trouver
un moyen de bouger d'ici parce que ça
craint ici
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas
un aimant il y a quelque chose de Fatal
mais on peut tomber plus bas encore
de l'autre côté du canal à quelques
mètres d'ici la dignité est un souvenir
[Musique]
c'est le territoire des junky
leur seul lien avec le reste du monde
c'est ONG qui distribue de l'eau et des
seringues
[Musique]
comment ça va avec la police
c'est mon lit et c'est ici que je dors
et je suis mort en même temps
c'est ce que je dis moi je suis une
personne morte qui continue à vivre
c'est comme ça quand tu prends de la
drogue et c'est comme ça quand tu prends
des rôles
combien arriverons à s'arrêter d'ici
combien il resteront
cette frontière rend fou les humains les
narcos par exemple dépensent des
fortunes pour construire des tunnels
il rachète des maisons les plus proches
de la frontière et il creuse
[Musique]
celle-ci ont été murée parce que leur
tunnels ont été découverts
il y a de l'électricité de l'aération et
même parfois des rails et des wagonnets
les narcos font passer de la cocaïne et
des hommes
drogue et immigration encore les deux
business sanglants de tiroir
[Musique]
Margarito passe sa vie branchée sur les
ondes de la police
c'est un vieux renard des faits divers
je passe la journée avec lui oui
là ils viennent de dire que le mec a
reçu une balle dans l'épaule
dans l'épaule
et qu'il a aussi été renversé par une
voiture
c'est la radio de la police municipale
et elle n'est pas cryptée
[Musique]
nous arrivons sur les lieux
le périmètre est sécurisé
[Musique]
Margarito s'est fait doubler par la
télévision
le blessé vient de mourir une bâche
recouvre le corps
à côté son vélo tordu par l'accident
[Musique]
Margarito apprend que le véhicule de
l'assassin a été retrouvé quelques rues
plus loin
de te laisser passer
c'est bien et alors vous l'avez attrapé
non non
juste à bagnole
il est venu lui a fait faire sa dernière
prière il lui a pété la gueule et il est
reparti il l'a défoncé avec son 4 4
c'est ça
il a utilisé quoi 9 mm non on ne sait
pas pour l'arbre
se disputer mais on ne sait pas pourquoi
bah oui ça arrive souvent ce genre de
truc
il te trouve et c'est tout
tu as vu comment il me traite les
policiers
quand tu arrives à avoir une interaction
avec eux tout se passe différemment ça
te facilite beaucoup le travail
il te connaissent ils savent qui tu es
et ils savent comment tu travailles et
ça c'est cool
mon travail je l'aime
[Musique]
c'est vraiment différent des métiers
normaux que je connais comme mécanicien
électricien avocat ou travaillant dans
un bureau
mon travail à moi il est très différent
moi je vois la réalité des choses tout
ce qu'il y a de bons et de mauvais dans
cette société
pas de chance pour Margarito aujourd'hui
c'est le mauvais qui est au programme
on vient de signaler un autre meurtre
sur le parking d'un supermarché
[Musique]
cette fois Margarito arrive le premier
et pourquoi la police scientifique elle
est toujours pas là
ils ont beaucoup de travail ils ont déjà
eu quatre mecs exécutés aujourd'hui ils
sont pris ailleurs ils arrivent il y a
qu'une seule équipe dans tout tiroir
[Musique]
il faut que le gouvernement fasse son
travail
la victime retournait à sa voiture avec
ses courses les œufs sont tombés du sac
il y a plusieurs douilles au sol juste à
côté du corps des tirs à bout portant
pour moi en tant que reporter
tout ce que vous êtes en train de voir
c'est plus les affrontements d'avance
parce que tu leur dois 150 euros
tout n'est pas forcément lié au crime
organisé
la journée de Margarito va se terminer
sur les hauteurs de tiroir
c'est une banlieue pour et la poudre a
encore parlé trois morts trois hommes
d'une même famille
la scène du crime restera inaccessible
la police attendue des couvertures
jusqu'au camion des pompes funèbres
que c'était en 2010 2011
cette semaine on est à 6 venant 9
homicides en une semaine
je ne m'étais pas rendu compte qu'elles
avaient ralenti depuis mon arrivée
et pourtant le pire est peut-être
derrière tiwana quand les cartels de la
drogue se faisaient la guerre
le cauchemar absolu a eu lieu en 2009
la police découvre des restes humains
dans des citernes d'acide
c'est cet homme Santiago Milan Lopez qui
faisait disparaître les corps
je les mettais dans une cuve avec de
l'acide et il partait comme ça
je l'ai acheté un peu n'importe où
un peu n'importe où et ça prenait
combien de temps pour
le pays est sous le choc la presse
trouve un surnom à Lopez elle pose sur
les héros le touilleur
[Musique]
ce matin j'ai rendez-vous devant la
maison de l'horreur
[Musique]
je retrouve sur place le père d'une
victime
Fernando avait un fils de 23 ans il l'a
vu partir de la maison un soir de 2007
avec des amis depuis c'est un deuil
impossible
c'est la cuisine
ici il y avait une cuve
et là une autre cuve
en dessous il y avait un feu alimenté
par une bouteille de gaz
[Musique]
juste là
il chauffait tout ça pendant 24 heures
et puis il revenait il ouvrait la vanne
et tout partait en bas et ça continuait
avec toujours plus de corps
ici il y avait un tuyau connecté à la
cuve
qui sont partis comme ça
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les familles ont investi les
lieux pour en faire un mémorial
[Musique]
mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
réellement ici c'est ça la question
[Musique]
où sont-ils que s'est-il passé ces
questions sans réponse on torturé des
centaines de familles
[Musique]
par exemple il y a des parents qui se
sont pendus il y a des parents qui ont
pris des médicaments pour s'endormir
et certains se sont ouverts les veines
de manière différente
dans mon cas je ressens
je ressens une certaine paix
parce que j'ai accepté de ne plus revoir
mon fils vivant
et de me dire qu'aujourd'hui il est mort
mais quand même c'est pas facile
d'expliquer ce que je vis est-ce que
vous vous êtes senti aider par les
autorités ou finalement vous vivez ça
seul
je me sens seule les seuls qui m'ont
vraiment aidé ce sont les papas des
victimes les familles
parce que si tu vas voir le gouvernement
il te dit ce qu'ils vont t'aider mais
dès que tu sors du bureau tu n'en
n'entends plus parler ils disent on va
t'aider mais ce sont des mensonges
mais l'État est bien incapable
d'apporter la seule chose qui pourrait
vraiment apaiser Fernando
moi ce que j'aimerais
enfin une preuve d'ADN qui dirait qu'on
a retrouvé mon fils
pour enfin pour pouvoir dire enfin à sa
mère regarde c'est tout ce que j'ai de
ton fils
pour que ma femme et moi on est un
endroit pour le pleurer
ensemble
c'est beaucoup d'émotions
[Musique]
où vont les âmes mortes de tyrowana dieu
s'il existe ne sait pas beaucoup occupé
de la ville ces derniers temps
[Musique]
en quelques jours j'ai été secoué parce
que j'ai vu par la puissance des drames
humains
[Musique]
mon séjour à tiwana se termine dernière
soirée et dernière patrouille avec la
police
ça part sur les chapeaux de roue
OK
le 4x4 il est à quelle hauteur le 4 4 à
quelle hauteur
[Musique]
de l'indépendance nous aussi on va vers
indépendance
je viens de voir passer ils arrivent par
saint Cristobal
attention c'est les individus armés
les fugitifs sont coincés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est lui qui conduisait
de l'extérieur je vois juste une douille
on poursuit la feuille du véhicule
apparemment pas d'armes mais une douille
du gros calibre
c'est toi le propriétaire de la voiture
oui c'est moi
tu travailles dans quoi dans la
construction
peut-être
qui a tiré la balle
[Musique]
Raphaël Mendes
avant n'était pas là par hasard
il y en a deux
codes policiers 10 50 armes courtes 10
51 harmelong
indice 50
c'est la deuxième la troisième
et une deuxième arme
deux armes courtes regardez bien le
premier pistolet est en or
l'homme à la casquette et quelqu'un
d'important
et c'est pas fini
ça peut partir à tout moment
s'il vous plaît écartez-vous
le couple est parti oui
il a dit
ça commence à faire beaucoup encore oui
il y en a encore
et un chargeur
[Musique]
et il y en a encore il faut vraiment
personne devant là
trois fusils d'assaut trois arbres de
points et des chargeurs
[Musique]
il y avait un arsenal derrière le
tableau de bord
l'homme à la casquette est probablement
à baron de la drogue
les policiers prennent peur
là pour qu'il vienne
on a besoin de renfort
[Musique]
si la nouvelle de l'arrestation se
répand le clan de l'homme à la casquette
pourrait tenter le tout pour le tout
pour le libérer
bon il faut mettre une voiture là et une
autre là
[Musique]
départ en urgence pour le commissariat
central allez on y va
[Musique]
à toutes les patrouilles on passe par le
boulevard allez vas-y fonce on le suit
ce seront mes dernières images de tiwana
un beau symbole bien sûr la guerre
contre les narcos n'est pas prête
s'arrêter mais ce soir la police a
remporté une bataille
[Applaudissements]
un tiroir le crime n'a pas réussi à tuer
l'espoir